the actress now author is spreading her
own positive message with her newest
children's book in her my purple world
series this is about the importance of
curiosity my favorite word kindness and
community this one is called the world
needs more purple schools kristen bell
good morning to you i remember your
first book bestseller by the way go you
congratulations thank you and after
reading i thought i want to be a purple
person and that's the message you're
trying to get yeah now you're taking it
into the schools because what well
because it was the next logical place so
we you know a lot of um different brands
work on kindness with kids we wanted to
be slightly more specific so what if
there were a set of principles
which ours are you know you need to
laugh a lot you need to work hard you
need to ask great questions both big and
small you need to use your voice but
also listen to other people exactly
which is a really important one and you
need to just be you because we like to
say you're the only you we've got and
it's really a love letter a giant love
letter to educators who have dealt with
so much on the front lines of everything
the last couple years it felt very
logical to move it into a place where
kids are familiar and give them some
specifics about it it's a children's
book kristen but it could also apply be
very helpful to adults because you said
we don't always have to agree and that's
okay and it's okay to be a little silly
too yes well we we encourage the
silliness and the laughing because you
can't be angry if you're laughing i've
tried it it's impossible that's true
that's true and it really was born of
this idea during a time when i felt like
even my dinner table was arguing all the
time and we were representing that to
our kids and i thought this isn't really
what i want to leave them you know just
everyone argues all the time
so what if we were able to create a set
of values or principles where it was
okay to listen to other people and
really at its core
that to encourage people to um celebrate
their own individuality their own quirky
wordness
uh weirdness their own road here and
then encourage
all of us to be curious about others and
their individuality this show is
definitely all about curiosity and gayle
i would say you're already a purple
person because you're beyond red or blue
categories i'd like to think so it's not
a political book but it's like
you can grasp the metaphor
we got it we got it right a combination
of red and blue yeah well i think the
best ideas and the best solutions for
any problem i know this from my marriage
because it's always in the middle dax
and i are polar opposites and the truth
or the solution's always in the middle
it you have to have diverse points of
view people who have different roads to
get there because uh uh you know a
recipe is not delicious with one
ingredient right so that's just not how
it works and now you're in dex yeah you
mentioned your marriage with dax
shepherd i often do he seems fun of
course and you also talked about your
dinner table but you're bringing people
into your bedroom with a podcast yes um
and it's it's about relationships well
that's the name of the podcast it's
called the honey and the hammer who's
the honey who's the hammer
obviously the honey he pick his own name
of course
that's what he calls us the honey and
the hammer like our most interesting
topic in the world what we're always
always talking about is like how hard it
is to be human we have to share earth
there's no getting around that but like
everybody's got a different point of
view it's hard to get along sometimes
and in our house um you know cleaning up
your own side of the street
accountability is a major thing and so
we thought let's take so we banter in
bed at night we literally this came out
of us him just putting the microphone on
like my bedside table for our random
discussions we have at night i like that
that being the intro and we've been
taking questions from his um armchair
expert um audience about you know
situations in their life a problem or an
issue with a sibling or a parent or an
in-law or a co-worker and kind of
walking them through it and mind you
we're not qualified to do this at all so
i'll admit that a hundred percent we're
just talking about our life but
experience makes you qualified exactly a
little bit but our goal is really to
allow people to vent about the issues
they have and then encourage them to say
okay what's what do you think your side
of the street is because maybe your side
of the street is just going yeah that
stinks that that happened between your
friends and family but maybe your job
now is to just take a deep breath and
change your expectations your kids read
your books
um what do they think of they're very
very lukewarm on all of my work
they're um kids are the best uh
grounding tool we have as humans because
they're they're really my kids at least
they're like living with two like yelp
trolls
that i didn't ask for who are constantly
reviewing everything um seven and nine
reviewing like everything well um my
naked body for instance they've been
very into lately at seven and nine those
things start to show up and go they go
like wow what's that boobs so i'll get
in the shower and they'll ask me why do
your boobs drip
oh and you know what they call them
their nickname for them what sloppy joes
i like sloppy joes
i don't hate it it's kind of a really
good joke but as an adult you just kind
of have to take it and go yeah it's your
time to shine i do too but i couldn't
say it
[Laughter]
but how many people walk up to you and
sing let it go because everybody would
like to see it come back do you see that
all the time despite that i don't even
sing that in the film i still get it i
know that's right i know no but i did i
i've been going around um on these shows
and officially with zero authority
announcing number three just because i
want to put it out there i'm like
manifest it into existence yes so you're
game i'm absolutely the world is good
very cool world is very game kristen
bell congratulations you have another
hit on your hands i predict thank you i
need to autograph before you leave thank
you so much the name of the book is
called the world needs more purple
schools it comes out today wherever you
like to buy your books